as an undergrad
i attended this seminar on a regular
basis and i'm honored to be here as a
speaker that's very exciting as
christina said i was a symbolic systems
undergrad i focused on hci so i feel
like i'm coming back to my roots
so one of the things that i do as a
product discovery coach is i work with
teams
and i help them make better decisions
about what they should build
by including their customer and that's
really what we're going to talk about
today
usually when i'm speaking to an industry
industry group i share this map and i
say look i've worked with teams all over
odds are these tactics are going to work
for you as well uh because in industry
we get a lot of skeptics that nothing
will work anywhere
i'm going to skip that part and just say
that look um
a lot of what you're going to hear today
really is grounded in what i learned in
the computer science department at
stanford and through the
symbolic
systems program at stanford and really
what i've done for the last uh
oh dear 20 plus years
is really look at how do we make this as
easy as possible for product teams to do
this day in and day out
because it's one thing to learn about
kind of the ideal world and the way of
doing things in the academic world and
then we get into business and it's messy
and it's more complicated than that so
we're going to talk a little bit about
what does this look like in practice
so uh these days we use a little bit of
different terms like as an undergrad i
learned about human centered design and
it was all about design thinking um all
of that obviously still exists in
industry but in the product world we're
starting to talk about this as discovery
versus delivery and the reason for that
name change is because it's really easy
in
industry to get obsessed with what did
we ship what are we producing and all
the work that we're doing to build ship
and maintain a production quality
product usually falls into this bucket
of delivery whereas discovery is usually
used to um
talk about the things we're doing to
make good decisions about what to build
i'd say over the last 20 years the
industry is starting to recognize that
if we want to make good decisions about
what to build we need to include our
customer in that process
now if you're sitting here
as a student focused on hci that sounds
obvious i will say i graduated into the
world in the late 90s thinking oh
business will just be human-centered and
then i've spent the last 20 years being
a little bit disappointed that wasn't
quite how it worked out um but we are
making major strides and one of the big
things that we're going to talk about
today if we look at the differences
between say like the academic view of
design thinking and what we're seeing
with discovery in the industry it's
really this simple we're starting to
recognize that we can't just include the
customer in the process that we also
have to take a continuous mindset
where we're looking at look digital
products are never done it's not like
netflix or facebook or um spotify are
going to show up to work one day and say
our product's good enough let's go home
there's always room for improvement and
so we're seeing this shift from a
project mindset to a more continuous
mindset we're definitely going to talk
about that today and the other big
difference we see between kind of this
jump from design thinking to a just this
discovery language is this like it's
this idea that it's not just designers
who do discovery but everybody involved
in
building the product needs to be
involved in this process so if i have
any computer scientists in the room that
want to spend their day writing code
this is just as applicable to you as it
is the folks who want to do the design
work
so let's dive in we're going to talk
about continuous discovery and i in my
book continuous discovery habits i
defined it as
weekly touch points with customers
by the team building the product where
they're conducting small research
activities in pursuit of a desired
product outcome
now there's a mouthful here here's the
idea we have a team in a company that's
responsible for building a product our
goal is to get them to engage with
customers on a weekly basis
when they're engaging with customers
they're doing a set of research
activities that helps them get fast
answers to that week's question
and the reason why we're doing this week
over week is because our business needs
us to drive a particular outcome and
we're using our research to derive that
outcome
now we're going to dive into this line
by line because it's there's a lot to
unpack here
we're going to start with why is it so
important that we engage with our
customers every week i'm going to tell
you again as an undergrad i thought this
was obvious because that's what i was
taught through the stanford computer
science department and through uh the
wonderful uh the early beginnings of the
d school i was there before the d school
um and so this may sound a little bit
obvious but in the in in business this
is not always obvious so i'm going to
share
a little bit about why this is so
important
so when you're working on a digital
product in a company you're literally
making product decisions every single
day
some of them are big strategic decisions
like which customer should we serve
uh what opportunities should we go after
um others are more mundane decisions
they're just everyday decisions that are
that are also important like what do we
label this button or what does the
underlying data model need to support
how should this feature work
most of us know that those big strategic
decisions need some customer input but
we forget that those everyday decisions
also need customer input
i'm going to guess that everybody in the
room and everybody on the zoom
has a mobile phone nearby so i want to
ask you to pick it up and i just want
you to scroll through
your apps and i'm going to guess that
every single one of you has at least
half a dozen if not a dozen or more apps
that you were excited about at one point
and they stopped working for you maybe
they never worked for you over time you
installed it you started using it and it
was disappointing or it worked for you
for a while and it didn't hold your
interest over time maybe they updated it
and it got worse for you
uh we have
way too many examples of this why does
this happen
my belief is it's because as product
people
um
it's really easy
to obsess about our products all day we
work on them from nine to five or many
of us from eight to six or seven and all
day long right
and what happens is we start to suffer
from this bias called the curse of
knowledge the curse of knowledge says
that as we develop expertise in a topic
we forget what it's like to not have
that expertise
you've probably experienced this if you
have a buddy who's studying like um some
archaic part of physics i'm not picking
on physics because i actually am
enamored with physics but you don't
understand it they have a hard time
explaining it to you because they forget
what it's like not to have the knowledge
you have well it turns out as product
people we suffer from the same bias as
well we forget what it's like to not
know where everything lives in our
product we forget what it's like to not
know exactly what order to do things and
so we go about making these daily
decisions
and we're making them from our point of
view
and they stop working for our customers
because to us it seems obvious it seems
easy but in reality we're moving further
and further away what from what's going
to work for our customers
thankfully there's a really simple way
to overcome this bias and that's simply
we just need to engage with our
customers more often
we need to see the gap between how we
think about the product and how our
customers think about the product now
thankfully most people in industry and
i'm guessing most people on this call
are really motivated to serve their
customers that's why we study human
computer interaction it's why we um go
out in industry and build digital
products
so really it is this simple if we can
just engage with our customers more
often and see that they think about
things differently from us we're going
to see that gap and we're already going
to be motivated to overcome that gap so
that's this idea of a continuous cadence
and engaging with our customers week
over week it's really to help us
remember who we're designing for who
we're building for and make sure that
the decisions that we make every day
continue to work for them
now the second line of the definition by
the team building the product
uh if you haven't been out in industry
yet you may not be aware that a lot of
companies
try to outsource this research they want
to hire a
design firm to do this for them or to
have like a business intelligence team
that's going out and doing research and
delivering it to the product teams
the challenge with this model is that
it's hard for third parties for
centralized teams to keep up with the
pace of individual product teams that
are creating and shipping software week
over week
we're working on a weekly cadence we
actually need to be equipped to get our
own fast answers because we need our
research to support the cadence that
we're working on and it's really rare
for a third party to be able to support
that cadence it's really rare for our
centralized research teams to be able to
support that cadence so there's this
idea of the team that's building the
product needs to be engaging with
customers directly
and this starts with this idea of a
product trio and this it really is this
idea of a cross-functional approach
where we're taking product managers
designers and software engineers and
asking them to collaborate from the very
beginning now i want to contrast this
with what we've historically done
historically a product manager wrote
requirements usually by working with
business stakeholders
once those requirements are written they
get handed off to a designer who does
all the design work
and then
both the requirements and the designs
get
engineers who are asked to build
what's wrong with this model
we see two major challenges first of all
we see a lot of rework
the product manager tries to do the best
they can to write requirements the
designer hits the snag we gotta rewrite
requirements redo right go back and
forth between the product manager and
the designer we finally get something we
can stamp off we hand them off to
engineers they estimate it's going to
take four times as long as we actually
have and what do we do we go back we
write requirements we reduce design
there's a lot of waste in this back and
forth
the second thing we see which is
actually more important in my book
is that typically in a company
the customer is talking to a customer
facing team a sales team an account
management team a support team and that
team is the product manager and that
product manager is communicating to
designers and engineers what their
requirements are and what happens is
it's like a game a telephone if you
remember this game from like kid
elementary school slumber parties we all
get kids in a row somebody whispers a
message it goes down the line and the
last kid says out loud what they heard
and everybody giggles why
because the message was distorted
this is what's happening in our
companies when we pass customer needs
down the line by the time we get to the
people who are building the product our
engineers and our designers the message
is distorted and it's no surprise we're
building the wrong
so in a continuous discovery world we're
getting the team that's building the
product to engage with customers
directly
so they we don't lose message fidelity
they get to hear firsthand from the
customer what they're building what they
should what they need and then they can
combine their knowledge of what's
possible with technology with those
customers knowledge of what they need
and they can build better products
now in an industry we have more than
these three rules on our team right we
typically have additional engineers
depending on your devops strategy you
might still have qa folks or release
managers depending on how you interface
with the rest of the business you might
have data analysts customer success
folks user researchers product marketing
managers
actually could have put 100 titles on
this slide so scrum masters program
managers project managers there's a
million of us
here's the idea
some people think only the trio
participates in discovery but that's not
true
we want everybody on our team to have
firsthand exposure to the customer the
idea of a trio is we want the trio
leading discovery this is our
decision-making team and the reason why
it's a subset of our bigger team is
because we're trying to make tradeoffs
between speed of decision making and
quality of decision making so the more
people involved in a decision the slower
we're going to go
however the more relevant roles involved
in a decision the better decision we're
going to make
so the core idea of a product trio is
how do we get the right cross-functional
roles in the room for the type of
decision that we're making and
historically we let business
stakeholders do this on their own we let
product managers do this on their own
what we're recognizing with the product
trio we need to take a cross-functional
approach so that we make better
decisions but we need to keep the
decision-making team small so we're able
to move fast and support our
week-over-week development
okay so we've tackled this first half
we've got this we've got this trio
that's leading our team they're engaging
with customers on a weekly basis
what are they doing when they engage
with customers on a weekly basis
and this is where we really need to
change our research methods we need them
to be smaller so they can be more
continuous
and we need to make sure that they're in
service of our desired product outcome
so we're gonna these last two lines
we're gonna tackle together
so
i know as an undergrad i was really
hyper focused on customer value how do i
serve my users and this is really
important we see a lot of companies
forget to be customer centric we
definitely want to bring this lens to
our work
but it's not enough
we also have to create value for our
business
and i know when i was 20 years old i
didn't fully appreciate this or
understand this i used to think well if
i just create value for a customer
they're going to pay money for something
and it will create value for my business
unfortunately that's not always true
and if you're currently a student you
may not be old enough to remember google
reader but it is one of the best
examples we have of a product that
customers loved
but it didn't create enough value for
google and they shut it down we see lots
of examples of this a lot of early stage
startups find things that customers want
that they're not willing to pay for
and what happens when we find ourselves
in this situation where we have a
desirable product that's not viable
we actually don't get to serve our
customer over time because our business
doesn't survive so i want to encourage
you to think about business value as a
way to earn the right to serve your
customer over time
if you're not also creating value for
your business your product will get shut
down and you will not be able to create
any value for your customer so we're
going to talk about how do we align
customer value and business value and i
want you to think about this as you're
earning the right to serve your customer
over time
so i created this visual it's called an
opportunity solution tree this is how i
help teams keep these needs aligned it
starts by defining an outcome
now in industry historically we've had
business stakeholders tell product teams
you need to build these specific
features that's an output focus
we're seeing a shift to business leaders
recognizing actually we can't predict
the future
we don't know what outputs right now we
should be building but we do know what
impact we need them to have on our
business
so we're telling our product teams
instead of prescribing features we're
telling them this is the impact we need
whatever you build to have
and we're measuring that with an outcome
i'm going to give you an example i'm
going to rely on netflix for my examples
i'm going to tell you i'm not affiliated
with netflix as a coach i've never
worked with netflix i use netflix
because i speak globally and they have
an amazing global presence so
everybody's broadly familiar with them
so netflix is a is a subscription
business what are some of the outcomes
they're going to care about
acquiring more customers
keeping them engaged over time
increasing the length of their
subscription
increasing how much money they spend
every month
this is how we're going to create value
for netflix you could imagine that a
product team at netflix could be charged
with look we're not sure what you should
build but we know whatever you build it
needs to increase subscriber retention
that's our business outcome that's how
we're going to make sure we stay focused
on creating value for the business
now business focus is not enough we do
want to stay focused on the customer as
well and so we're going to discover the
opportunities
that we think have the potential to
drive our outcome now opportunity is a
little bit of jargon it stands for unmet
customer needs
pain points and desires
so this is where we're looking at what's
the customer value that if we
created it would drive our business
value we're aligning these two things so
the opportunity space is infinite i
could spend the rest of my life trying
to serve customer needs
but i may not create value for my
business so we're going to filter the
opportunity space based on the
opportunities that have the potential to
drive our outcome so in our netflix
example i'm going to look at what are
the unmet needs pain points and desires
that if i addressed them would have the
potential to drive subscriber retention
and this is how i'm going to align
customer value and business value
now in this model outputs still matter
we do have to discover the solutions
that have the potential to drop to
address those outcomes in a way that
will create business value that's really
it's in the solution space is where
we're creating the value right we're
giving customers solutions that address
their needs in a way that supports our
business
so what we're going to look at are two
small research activities that a product
can team can do week over week
one's going to help them discover
opportunities to discovering those unmet
needs pain points and desires and the
other is going to help them discover the
right solutions
of course all of this starts by setting
a good outcome
now i'm going to tell you especially if
you're undergrad in the room when you
graduate into the world you might think
great this is how the world works
i'm sorry to tell you most companies are
not yet outcome focused this is where
we're moving towards there's a lot of
companies talking about how to do this
some of them are kind of doing it
few are very good at doing it but the
good news is we're seeing a lot of
companies move in this direction
we are swimming upstream stream against
about 100 years of business history
where culture change is slow
but we are starting to see
executives at companies start to talk
about outcomes and work with their teams
and say look this is how you can create
business patent and we're seeing this as
a two-way negotiation where the leaders
are saying this is what we need from you
and the product teams are saying this is
how much impact we can have by when
that's the ideal view we're getting
closer and closer every day
once that's in place we're now looking
at what's the first small research
activity we're going to do on a regular
basis
and that's we're interviewing
to discover opportunities so we're
interviewing our customers to uncover
unmet needs unmet pain points and unmet
desires
and because the opportunity space is
always changing we're interviewing week
over week we're continuously investing
in what we know about our customer
now in industry it's not so easy because
companies like to put rules in place
like only these people are allowed to
talk to customers or only i'm allowed to
reach out to a customer as the sales
person and you as the product person are
not allowed to talk to our customer
so one of the things i do with product
teams right away to help them adopt a
sustainable habit of talking to their
customers week over week is we've got to
overcome this hurdle of it's hard to
find someone to talk to
and so what i recommend is that teams
start by automating their recruiting
process
now this is going to sound magical but i
want my teams to wake up on monday
morning and already have an interview on
their schedule without them having to do
anything
so it just appears
the most common way to do this is to set
up workflows within your product where
you're able to recruit people while they
visit your product or service so what
you're seeing on the screen here is an
example this comes from snag job they're
hourly job boards they help restaurant
workers and retail workers find work
they own they don't show this to
everybody they can just show it to a
percentage of their population you can
see they're offering a 20 amazon gift
card for 20 minutes of their time this
is actually really valuable in the
united states a lot of our states people
are making the federal minimum wage
which i think is something like seven
dollars and 29 cents an hour
and snagajob is paying them 20 for 20
minutes of their time this is an
important thing to get right you want to
offer a big reward for a small ask
that's what gets people to click on that
button and say yes i'll talk to you
once they do that they can pair this
with scheduling software so the
interview automatically shows up on
their calendar this is by far the most
common way i'm seeing teams automate
their recruiting process it's so that
they don't even have to think about it
interviewing a customer is just like
going to any other meeting
now for some product teams recruiting
their end users isn't the right strategy
they actually need to recruit those
people's bosses they need to recruit the
decision makers the buyers
and that's why we're going to leverage
our colleagues
everybody working in a company has
colleagues whose job it is to be on the
phone all day every day with customers
these are our sales teams our account
management teams our support teams
and what we're going to do is we're
going to find triggers for them we're
going to say when you're talking to a
customer who's experiencing this need or
pain point go ahead and put an interview
on my calendar
so these strategies might feel really
foreign if you're currently a student
and you haven't worked in industry but
i'm going to tell you they're really
critical for building this habit of how
do we engage with our customers every
week because what we're doing is we're
making it easier to talk to a customer
than to not talk to a customer and
that's our goal
once we have a customer in the room or
on a zoom call we now need to talk about
how do we ask the right questions
now if you've interviewed a customer
before my guess is that you've come up
with a big discussion guide it's full of
all these who why how questions the
challenge with this strategy is it
is we tend to get speculative answers
and our goal in an interview is to avoid
speculation i'm going to give you an
example if i were to ask christina to um
if i wanted to learn about christina's
netflix behavior my intuition is to ask
christina questions like what do you
like to watch who do you watch with what
device are you watching on how do you
decide what to watch and here's the
thing
christina's going to have answers to
every single one of these questions
because that's how our brain works our
brain is very good at generating fast
answers
the problem is
those answers aren't necessarily going
to reflect her behavior in reality and
it's not because christina is trying to
deceive me in fact i trust she's not
it's because we all experience cognitive
biases which most of the time are
cognitive shortcuts that help us out
sometimes
they lead to faulty answers
and when we're talking about customer
behavior we tend to answer questions
from our ideal selves we tend to be
optimistic about our behavior we all
think we're above average drivers than
we are we all think we're good listeners
we all think we work out more often than
we do we all think we let drink less
alcohol than we do right we're just not
very reliable when it comes to answering
direct questions out of context
thankfully there's an easy way to fix
this we're going to collect specific
stories about past behavior so i'm going
to ask christina tell me about the last
time you watched netflix and i'm going
to listen for where was she who was she
with what device was she watching on so
i can still get my answers to those
direct questions
but because i'm grounding them in a
specific instance i'm going to get far
more reliable answers
there's another benefit to collecting
specific stories
when christina tells me a specific story
i get context i get to imagine i get to
visualize where she is
i get the sequence of activities that
occurred and as i collect that story
i start to hear
unmet needs unmet pain points and unmet
desires
and this is what allows me to map out
the opportunity space
and the value of collecting all these
unmet needs paying points and desires
and visualizing them
is now i can make a strategic decision
about how i want to serve my customer
for those of you that have had summer
internships or have have work experience
you've probably experienced this problem
in companies where
the last customer you talk to
dictates what you build
we overreact to the last conversation we
had
if we instead collect all these need
pain points and desires in one place we
can actually look at the set and say
actually this one's more important than
this one
and i see a lot of teams skip this step
because we're too busy overreacting
now we do want to make a strategic
decision we want to pick a target
opportunity to start with we're
basically going to say this is how we're
going to create value for the customer
we're going to solve this specific need
or pain point
and then when we do that what a lot of
teams do
is they jump to their first solution
they have an idea and they immediately
start asking is my idea good or not
and the problem with this framing is
decision making researchers call this a
whether or not decision
this framing is going to exacerbate a
couple of known cognitive biases
the first is called the escalation of
commitment if you've read robert
cialdini's book influence he talks about
this bias
the more we invest in something the more
we identify with it the more we identify
with it in the product world we tend to
fall in love with our ideas when we fall
in love with our ideas we exacerbate a
second cognitive bias called
confirmation bias
confirmation bias says
we're going to notice all the evidence
that says our idea is fantastic and
we're going to completely miss the
evidence that suggests our idea is
flawed so even if we do the right things
we go to our customers we try to get
feedback we test our idea
if we're working with one idea at a time
it's really hard to get good feedback
i'm seeing a question about the ikea
effect
i have heard of the ikea effect but i
can't recall off the top of my head
exactly what it is so if you want to
just describe it really quickly i can
help connect the dots here for
sure okay so
thankfully there's an easy way to fix
this and what we're going to do
is we're going to set up a good compare
and contrast decision instead of working
with one idea at a time we're going to
work with a set of ideas and we're going
to compare and contrast them against
each other when we compare and contrast
we trick our brain into seeing the pros
and cons of each option
we already know this right this is why
we
um
talk to multiple companies when we're
looking for a job or we look at multiple
apartments and we're looking for a place
to live we're comparing and contrasting
we sometimes forget to do this in the
product world
um
yeah okay yes the ikea effect if you
enjoy things that you build there's
probably a little bit of escalation and
commitment in there right you spend a
lot of time building a piece of
furniture and now you love that piece of
furniture um that is a little bit of
escalation at the moment in there
escalation and commitment is really more
about
um if i have to defend my idea i'm gonna
fall i'm gonna like my idea even more
right i'm going to dig my heels in and
get stubborn about it so this idea of
like if i'm going to get feedback from
you about my idea i'm going to want to
defend it and then i'm going to get
stubborn about it whereas if instead we
compare and contrast now i don't have
one horse in the race i have multiple
and it's a lot easier for me to have
some distance and be a little bit more
objective
and this idea of comparing and
contrasting is really powerful i want to
give you a visual to help you remember
this is usain bolt he's currently the
world record holder in the 100 meter
dash
if you saw usain bolt running around a
track and i asked you is he fast
i want you to hear a whether or not
question is he fast or not
and i want you to ask relative to what
this is exactly what i want you to do
when you catch yourself saying is my
idea good or not is it good relative to
what so let's play with this a little
bit is usually in bolt fast relative to
a cheetah
probably not
is he fast relative to a tesla
wow i would pay to see that race in the
first 100 meters
i have no idea
is he fast relative to other humans
absolutely what we're seeing in the
photo on the right is a compare and
contrast decision with a clear front
runner
literal front runner and there's another
thing i want to highlight about this
photo every runner in this race is an
elite runner so we're not taking two bad
ideas and comparing them to our favorite
idea we're taking three good ideas and
we're comparing and contrasting until we
have a clear front runner
this is a really important idea
to keep in mind when you're evaluating
solutions
because a lot of teams go through all
the right motions they do the right
things but they don't get as much value
from them because they're falling prey
to the escalation of commitment and a
confirmation bias so we want to set up
good compare and contrast decisions
now in industry the reason why most of
us don't do this is because we're stuck
in this project-based research world
where the way we test our ideas is we
build them and we a b test them to
figure out if we built the right thing
that's insanity we're doing all the work
before we learned if it was the right
thing
we even see this in the design world we
prototype the entire solution we do all
the design work up front before we know
if it's right
there's a better way to do this that
allows us to work with multiple
solutions at once i'm going to return to
my netflix example to illustrate this i
want you to imagine we interviewed a
bunch of netflix customers and we heard
over and over again i want to watch live
sports so we generated three different
ways to solve this need
the first is we're going to partner with
tv channels like nbc abc tnt whoever
espn whoever shows your favorite sport
we're going to partner with those
channels and we're going to integrate a
live feed of that channel into netflix
second solution we're going to partner
with different sports leagues so we're
going to partner with major league
baseball the national hockey league mls
and we're going to license their games
directly and push their games into the
netflix interface
third solution we're netflix we don't
want to get good at sports we're going
to partner with fubotv who's already
done all this work and we're just going
to bundle our solutions together
okay
these are big solutions we can't just
build them and see what happens
the key
to comparing and contrasting and testing
multiple solutions is to take our ideas
and to break them down into their
underlying assumptions
and to rapidly test those assumptions
now the reason why we don't do this is
because we're often blind to our own
assumptions
so first we have to do the work to
surface the assumptions our ideas depend
upon
in the product world we tend to make
assumptions in five categories
three of them are based on this venn
diagram that's become pretty common i'm
going to start with these three and i'm
going to add two more the first is
desirability assumptions why do we think
our customers want the solution
and why do we think they're willing to
do what we need them to do to get value
from it
the second is viability assumptions is
this good for our business remember if
we're not creating business value we
won't earn the right to serve our
customer over time
the third is feasibility assumptions is
it possible do we have the necessary
skills and abilities can we create the
required technology
the fourth we're getting pretty good at
and i will say this is the biggest
change i see it since the day i
graduated today in industry and that's
usability assumptions we are seeing most
teams care about can people understand
it can they find it are they able to do
what they need to do don't get me wrong
we still have more to do here we are
getting much stronger here
the fifth category as an industry i'm
embarrassed to say we're terrible at and
i'm really hoping we start to get better
at it and that's ethical assumptions is
there any potential harm in building
this solution
and this is where we want to look at the
ethics of the data we're collecting
who we're choosing to serve who we're
leaving out are we unintentionally
replicating the inequities we see in our
communities in the products that we
build and over the last two years two or
three years we've seen a lot come out
about this that's pretty heartbreaking
um and i think we can be doing a better
job and one of the ways we can do this
is to be deliberate about generating the
ethical assumptions our ideas depend
upon
okay
knowing these five categories will help
you can ask what are the desirability
assumptions we're making what are the
ethical assumptions we're making but
you'll still have blind spots so i'm
going to introduce a second strategy
we can story map our ideas and use our
story maps to help us generate
assumptions
here's how a story map works it's the
yellow boxes on this slide we're going
to fast forward into the future and
we're going to assume our solution
already exists
and we're going to map out what our
customer has to do to get value from the
solution so we're going to assume we've
already integrated something like nbc
into netflix let's say we want to watch
the olympics because the nbc airs the
olympics
what does a customer have to do to get
value from this solution
first they have to decide to watch the
game
then they have to choose a streaming
service if we work at netflix we want
them to choose netflix then they have to
open that service then they have to find
nbc
and then they have to watch whatever's
on nbc
here's the value of this very simple
story map i can now ask for each step
what needs to be true for my customer to
take that action
so in order for my customer to decide to
watch the olympics
they have to want to watch sports they
have to be a sports fan
in order for them to choose netflix they
have to know that netflix has nbc
they have to want to watch sports on
netflix meaning they don't already have
fubo td and they're already satisfied
with that solution
they have to be able to find our service
at the time the game is on
our service has to be available at the
time the game is on
they have to know what channel the game
is on
we have to be able to partner with that
channel in an economically viable way
that that event can't be subject to
local broadcast regional blackout rights
if you've ever experienced that that's
pretty frustrating right
now when we get into viewing sports
we have to be able to create a good
viewing experience
i'm going to share i'm a hockey fan and
most streaming services do not know how
to stream a hockey game here's why
hockey games can end at any time in the
playoffs they go into infinite overtimes
what do most streaming services do
they put a bar at the bottom if you're
watching it on a replay they tell you
when it ends it ruins the hockey game it
drives me nuts terrible viewing
experience for that type of content
right so we have a whole set of
assumptions around
what's the right viewing experience
given that we're now showing new content
what's the value of doing this
each of these assumptions are easier and
faster to test than the whole idea
the other value of this is each idea
will depend on different assumptions
when we test assumptions from different
ideas
that's what allows us to compare to
collect compare and contrast data
in one idea my customer needs to know
what channel the game is on
in another idea they need to be able to
just find the sporting event within
netflix in a third idea they have to
install a whole separate app
as i test the assumptions about are they
willing to do those things do they know
what channel the game is on are they
willing to add another app can they find
the sporting event mixed in with all
these movies and tv shows
as i test those assumptions
i start to get a sense for
which of my solutions might be a clear
front runner
now there's several ways to test
assumptions i'm not going to go into a
ton of detail in the interest of time
because i want to make sure that we can
get to q a but i will share we can
rapidly test assumptions with prototypes
the key idea here is they're super
focused on a teeny tiny assumption
they're not big prototypes they're small
prototypes designed to get us fast
answers quickly
we can test assumptions with one
question surveys i can ask you have you
watched a sporting event in the past
week and quickly learn if you're a
sports fan
i can test assumptions by looking at the
data i already have about you i have
behavioral analytics i have support
tickets i have sales conversations
are my customers already exhibiting the
behavior i would expect to see
we're going to blaze through this part
on testing assumptions i'll tell you
where you can learn more at the end
for our feasibility assumptions we can
run research spikes research spikes are
time-boxed activities where we ask our
engineers to investigate something to
turn it into an assumption test
we need to give them a very specific
task for example maybe we have an
assumption
nbc can provide appropriate metadata
about what's on tv right now
we ask our engineers to collect 24 hours
of data and to evaluate how often
do we get appropriate data that we can
just display in our interface this is
allowing us to eva this is helping us
evaluate how easy or difficult will it
be to test this particular solution
by testing specific assumptions we're
collecting the data we need across our
solutions
to set up a good compare and contrast
decision
okay we just covered a ton of ground we
started with this definition of the
continuous discovery team they're
starting with an outcome
they're interviewing every week to
discover unmet needs pain points and
desires that's the opportunity space
we're mapping out the opportunity space
to get a big picture view of how we
might reach our outcome
we're choosing a target opportunity
we're working with a set of solutions
comparing and contrasting them against
each other by testing their underlying
assumptions that's what's allowing us to
quickly evaluate which of these ideas
might work
i know we covered a lot of ground really
quickly i will share everything we've
covered is covered in depth in my book
continuous discovery habits i wrote this
book to be a practical hands-on guide
for product teams if you're interested
in learning what it might be like to
work as a product manager or designer or
even a software engineer on an outcome
driven team i recommend checking out
this book
all right i think we're ready for
questions
one yay
[Applause]
wonderful thank you so much theresa um
[Music]
well if anybody has questions on the
zoom um just go ahead and type it in and
she'll answer it are there any questions
here in person
yes
i i can repeat it okay
um what do you recommend um you know
when you say you have to engage the
customers through
um surveys that you launch on your
product what if you're a company that's
like still zero and you're still
starting off lean how do you manage that
so how can you get data from customers
if you are a startup that has no
customers how can you run a survey on
uh no customers is that right okay
okay um yeah so first of all i will
share i have a blog post coming out on
this very topic
uh
i think april 20th but i'm going to give
you the highlights
uh so
if you don't have a product yet you're
early stage startup you're still
pre-product or you have a product but
you don't have customers yet
there's two ways to think about how to
test your ideas first you need to go to
where your customers are
and second you can pay to pull them to
you so let me give an example let's say
that i want to start a company helping
podcasters um
build their audience so first time
podcasters i'm going to help them get to
their first 500 listeners
how do i find podcasters as customers
that i can help
first of all there's a podcaster
subreddit that i can go hang out in and
meet podcasters what i don't want you to
do is just go to that subreddit and say
hey will you be an interview participant
because you're not going to get any
responses people do that all the time
and it's considered spam instead hang
out there
see what questions they're asking help
where you can build relationships and
then use those relationships to then
interview those people
that's one strategy so go to where they
hang out the second strategy is we can
build landing pages and use advertising
to drive people to those landing pages
now if you have a teeny tiny budget
there's actually a lot of ways to get
free ads most of the big app platforms
will give you like 30 bucks or 100 bucks
just to bring you in as a customer so
you can actually make quite a bit of
progress even on a really small budget
because you don't need hundreds of
people you just need a few first people
to talk to and then once you find the
first couple of people end every
conversation with who else should i talk
to
every podcaster knows another podcaster
and that can get you your next
conversation
okay we have a question from yes so we
have a question i'm kind of curious on
ways that these kinds of discovery
habits can be implemented in internships
like you know
usually a lot of students i guess our
only form of work experience before we
graduate our internships and how do you
think you know implementing those kinds
of uh discovery habits uh would be good
in the context of say
internships at either a startup or a
large company like stay at google or
something like that
yeah here's where i tell you most of the
places that you work are not going to
work this way
that's the unfortunate reality is that
we're just starting as an industry to
move in this direction and there's a
william um is it william gibson yeah
william gibson quote that i love which
is the future is already here it's just
unevenly distributed so there are lots
of teams that are working this way
they're just at a small percentage of
the com of the companies out there and
so most people in our industry face this
question of like how can i as an
individual adopt these habits if my
organization doesn't work this way i
will tell you there's an entire chapter
in the book about this very question
and i will give you the highlights
i as a full-time employee at early stage
startups never worked anywhere
where my executives said
oh teresa you have a human-centered
design background awesome go do that
here they did not ever say that once
but because i had a hci background i
stubbornly did it
i found a way to talk to my customers i
found a way to uncover unmet needs i
found a way to work this way
regardless of how my organization worked
and you have a lot of ability to do that
because first of all you have an amazing
network at stanford you know a ton of
people you have people in your network
that are like your customer
so you have a way to get to people like
your customer regardless of who your
customer is
you also have a way to influence in
one-on-one conversations with other
people in your organization make friends
with a salesperson or a support person
and get access to customers that way so
i really encourage everybody regardless
of your organizational context to look
for the smallest ways you can start to
adopt these habits yourself
because i promise you you will build
much better versions of your of your
products even if you're being told
exactly what to build
okay we have another question from the
audience oh
yeah yeah hi uh i i found one thing very
interesting you mentioned in the
beginning that many startups find
products that are actually valuable for
the customer and then they are just out
of an economic perspective not viable
however many of the greatest companies
there are in the beginning weren't
viable
out of business perspective and then
over time found this viability so how do
you kind of find this sweet spot where
you say this is worth pursuing although
right now this might not be economically
viable how do you see that there is like
a trajectory that this is a valid
business case
i'm not sure i don't i know how to
answer this question without being
controversial so i'm just going to do it
yeah so first of all the vast majority
of startups do not find the product that
customers want so that's the first
problem desirability is probably the
number one reason why customers fail and
it's because founders focus on their
scratching their own itch and they don't
bother
seeing if anybody else has the same need
so that's the first thing there are
startups that do find
um desirable products but they don't
focus on the economics that's what i had
mentioned earlier in the topic in the
talk and that's a big mistake
now the heart of your question was
some companies go a long time without a
business model and then they get and
then they succeed
that only happens when you have
venture-backed funding that is the only
way that can happen somebody has to fuel
that growth
and the thing to know about
venture-backed funding
is that the only way you will succeed is
if you are a home run success
and that comes at a cost
the bigger like the the bigger success
you go after
the higher chance of failure and i'm not
saying you shouldn't go after that
because if you are willing to take those
risks that's fine you just and i know in
silicon valley we don't always talk
about this openly but if you're gonna
take if you're going to take the path of
i'm going to get big as fast as possible
and i'll figure out the economics later
that means you have to get really big
you're going to spend a ton of money
and your chance of failure is going to
be through the roof now lots of some
people do that and they have wild
successes and that's what we read about
in the paper
but there's other paths to building
products that people like and there's
other paths to building viable companies
and i think that's a big narrative
that's missing particularly in
stanford's area
100 thank you teresa we have another
question here
i had a question about the research
research spikes that you mentioned can
you talk a little bit more about i guess
what that process looks like and then do
you get pushback from engineers who
maybe think they don't have assumptions
that need to be tested or like why
should they be doing this
you know what i actually find that
engineers are some of the best folks at
identifying and testing assumptions and
it's because
a lot of engineers are really analytical
and a lot of generating assumptions is a
little bit of this devil's advocate just
asking just confirming questions kind of
activity and that's exactly the work
that we do when we're coding what are my
edge cases what could go wrong um what
are the situations that i haven't
accounted for and so those skills are
actually really applicable to trying to
take an idea and deconstruct it into its
underlying assumptions so i actually
find most of the time engineers are
awesome partners on this
now it's really easy especially for a
young engineer to think like oh it's
going to be really easy to build the
solution i don't have to test my
assumptions
you know what try it
here's what i would recommend
write down what you think is going to be
easy like i one of the things i tell
everybody one of the most impactful
things you can do keep a decision
journal
i'm deciding not to test this because i
think it's going to work out and it's
obvious here's what i think is obvious
now i'm going to go do that thing and
i'm going to reflect on what actually
happened and i promise you there will be
a gap 90 of the time
and that will help train you to see you
are making faulty assumptions that do
need to be tested
thank you so much well i see we've come
up on noon so we're going to go ahead
and release you uh to have your lunch as
well
thank you so much teresa can we give her
one last round of applause
yay thank you so much for spending your
time with